when you have this face to face with
death you instantly lock into what are
you doing with today Ashton Kutcher sits
down for his first joint interview with
his twin brother Michael the actor has
an emotional discussion with Michael in
a trailer for Paramount pluses the
checkup with Dr David Aegis I was unable
to walk and then suddenly you can't see
when you have this face to face with
death you instantly lock into what are
you doing with today Michael was born
with Cerebral Palsy and had a heart
transplant yeah I'm just grateful to to
wake up every day Ashton first talked
publicly about his brother's Health
struggles in 2003 and during a chat with
the Today Show last year Michael
admitted he was very angry that his
famous sibling shared his disorder with
the world quote I didn't want to be the
face of CP I never talked about it
Michael adds that he off often tried to
hide his disorder which he was diagnosed
with when he was three his cerebral
palsy impacts his speech hearing
mobility in his right hand and vision I
almost died at Birth almost died with a
heart transplant but I'm still here but
what is my purpose yeah now my brother
is a major celebrity how do I utilize
kind of the notoriety that I built kind
of through that for the greater good and
to be able to give back to people you
know and those are some some great
lessons that my brother taught me
Michael said he forgave Ashton or Chris
Ashton's first name as he and his family
call him and thanked him for changing
his life quote Chris did me the biggest
favor he's ever done because he allowed
me to be myself I was finally ready to
tell my story and I knew because of my
twin I'd have a big reach and it looks
like Ashton will be telling more of his
own story on the show too I was unable
to walk and then suddenly you can't see
back in August the actor appeared on
running wild with Bear Grylls The
Challenge and shared a recent Health
scare I had this weird super rare form
of vasculitis
so like knocked out my
vision and knocked out my hearing yeah
and knocked out like all my equilibrium
it took me like a year to like build it
all back up shortly after Ashton shared
all that E.T was with his wife Mila
Kunis he kind of just power through you
go you you you deal with it with
whatever health issue comes your way uh
but you still got kids you still got a
family you still got you gotta do you
gotta live life yeah and I think that
it's you know we are so fortunate to
have one another but as far as like
sitting there and and
incessantly talking about things no we
gotta do
[Music]
foreign